hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the Thursday afternoon
just before Friday Monday morning
podcast and I'm just checking in on you
hey Bill dude what the [ __ ] why are you
checking in on us so [ __ ] late this
week dude I would you have a [ __ ]
hernia is that what happened what did
you did you get hit by a car
uh no I it's been the most difficult
podcast I've ever had to record you guys
I need a start-up for my emotions
honestly honestly I don't know what
happened I [ __ ] I got real busy and
then I recorded the podcast and for some
reason there was no audio I can't figure
out what the [ __ ] I did to my mouth oh I
did something all freckles did something
so this is my second attempt was believe
it or not I believe was on Thursday I
was on Wednesday I swear to god that dog
ate my homework that's literally what
I'm telling you in a podcasting way so
I'm back to one of my original mixers
here thank God I didn't throw it out
thank God I'm a bit of a pack rat you
guys know actually I didn't want to
throw it out because I was gonna give it
away to somebody is what I wanted to do
that was the thing I was gonna be like
do you mind you realize the amount of
times a semi known comic said the word
[ __ ] into this mixer mixer mixer and I
thought it'd be worth something to
somebody that they would take it but I
never got around to doing that thank God
I had a backup mixer all right that's
the level then ah you got a mixer buddy
I got a mixer and a backup mixer what
the [ __ ] do you got you know if they
still had MTV Cribs right now I would be
on it or lifestyles of the rich and
famous they have one and a half mixes
all right it's Saturday Saturday all
right in mole freckles has been alcohol
free for nine miserable [ __ ] weeks
it's actually you know something I'm at
the point now I don't even give a [ __ ] I
don't think I think about it
occasionally but
now when I think about it I think but
why would I go back to that huh
Oh Billy Booz face sitting back enjoying
himself after a long day of hard work of
performing words that other people wrote
do you guys realize realize how hard it
is to be an actor sometimes to just show
up and say things that people already
said for you want a piece of paper
that's one of the reasons why this
week's a little Crazy's uh I got a
little acting gig over the next week or
so and I'm on General Hospital now and
I'm not allowed to say everything you're
not allowed to say now cuz you got all
these [ __ ] [ __ ] everybody tries to
figure out what you're on and then they
start I don't know what they do and then
somehow they know what you're doing
before you even shoot it that's like the
level of Technology okay if you actually
say what you're acting on and somebody
listening to you on a podcast has a
drone with one of those GoPros somehow
they will know what scene you're doing
but the next day before you are before
you do okay speaking of drones do you
know that the next level of UBA the next
level of lift the next level of [ __ ]
is really too [ __ ] there's only two
of them either take lift or waste it's
like back in the day when there was VHS
or beta and everybody chose VHS so think
about that the next time you're gonna
get in a car with a stranger huh there's
a bunch of weird movies coming out now
but I don't understand you know there's
a [ __ ] documentary right now in in
Sundance it's I can't I glanced at it
quickly I think it said it was four
hours long it can't be four hours long
it's a documentary about two now adults
who said when they were kids they
allegedly got molested by Michael
Jackson now I I gotta ask you this why
the [ __ ] what I want to sit down and
watch that I'm gonna sit there with a
bucket of popcorn and some [ __ ]
Junior Mints all right let me hear the
worst or
that can happen to a kid you know and
you know some people say oh they're just
doing it for mine I don't know what the
[ __ ] app but I wasn't there but let's
you know true or untrue I don't want to
listen to those stories what kind of a
[ __ ] person wants to [ __ ] sit down
you going to the movies you know you're
gonna get something to eat
and you're sitting there at the counter
oh what do you feel like indulging in
before we listen to this horror I don't
know when I go back oh I think when I
saw Chandler's list I believed I was
eating popcorn I mean that decide it
certain movies they should not you
should not be sitting there stuffing
your face with food right we now have a
documentary about the genocide in Rwanda
and out of respect for the victims none
of you fat Americans will be allowed to
eat over the next two hours no [ __ ]
groans hashtag hypoglycemic anyways so
they they getting back to the drones the
next level of uber is that they're
actually gonna have I swear to God like
unmanned drones well I guess none of
them really manned right now that you
can get into like a life-sized one like
a human sized one and you get in this
[ __ ] thing and you fly over the
traffic like like I do when I fly one of
the helio type copters and I have to
tell you this you are out of your
[ __ ] mind if you remember the LASIK
eye surgery when that first came out you
remember that and there'd be a couple of
[ __ ] people go oh my god I can see it
to the future but like one out of every
15 would be like Maya
what did you do I'll never see again
yeah there's going to be the first week
of LASIK eye surgery version of that I
want to know how in the [ __ ] the FAA is
gonna [ __ ] sign off on that one you
know god damn well there
it was a glitch you're gonna have the
gus grissom [ __ ] something's gonna
happen you know it's bad enough that
you're gonna have the person up there
careening down or falling down to their
death you're gonna be sitting there
[ __ ] watching and if elf up up but
that better bett have enough [ __ ]
hipsters gonna fall through your goddamn
ceiling tight jeans and all you know
Hitler Youth [ __ ] fade with the I
know how to make shoes by hand beard
that he thought these gonna have it's
gonna come fallin right through your
[ __ ] ceiling I don't know you know
you know you'd think if [ __ ] people
like Elon Musk are trying to figure out
a way to drill through the goddamn earth
and now they're gonna have unmanned
unmanned people unmanned people unmanned
devices flying people around up there
you think it's some people at some point
Jesus Christ the kid speak somebody
would address the [ __ ] population
problem signs you have too many people
we're gonna have unmanned drones flying
people over densely populated areas hey
everybody
you have cellphones you have laptops how
many times what what's the longest
they've consistently worked before you
had to refresh it or shut it down or
restart it or take it over to the Apple
store so one of the geniuses can't be
like oh oh I finally I found the problem
people in aviation you can't hit a
refresh button okay yeah they refresh
they refresh by hosing off wherever the
[ __ ] you crash-landed let's refresh this
scorched earth and then it'll be like
well should they in stop like horror
struck today when two hipsters from
Silver Lake we're trying to get from
silver
like out to Santa Monica to go to a
craft beer tasting [ __ ] festival
whatever that whatever the [ __ ] it is
they do to go to a pocketwatch
convention yet and then they'll follow
through some [ __ ] you know I'm not
paid in a month air traffic controllers
[ __ ] irony struck today I don't know
how do you you're out of your [ __ ]
mind and I also got to think it's gonna
be at least three hundred bucks per trip
that'll become some elite thing and then
they'll be like you know we have to have
affordable unmanned drone why you saying
unmanned bill you know why because man
learned how to fly not women and I'm
sure when Hollywood does the [ __ ]
next biopic of Orville and Wilbur it'll
be like well why can't it be Orville in
Wilma and they'll make one of them a
woman and they'll make some sort of
backstory that one of them actually
identified as female just so they don't
get yelled at on Twitter Orville and
will m'a we're very proud of this that
the real story of [ __ ] Devil's Island
whatever the [ __ ] they call ever they
they actually where they learned how to
fly it's like some Devils something or
other now I'm sure there's some jesus
[ __ ] group out there Jesus Freak
group we'll just talk about that's why
you tell you right now that's why flight
is evil ain't you ever read the story of
Icarus they flew too close to the Sun
and his and his winged his winged beast
caught on fire and he went all the way
back down to earth and he continued to
fall to earth through the earth into the
pits and the flames of hail I don't know
what I'm talking about and I don't give
a [ __ ] I'm just contractually obligated
here to give you guys some sort of an
effort for 30 minutes okay that's what
you get not at me oh by the way speaking
of efforts Sunday tomorrow Sunday
whatever [ __ ] January 27th 2019 this is
the this is the soft open of a sports
world without football for the next six
months this is the one
if he can't you know god bless ESPN
god bless Fox Sports the way the way
they're gonna be keep yammering on on
Sunday as if something sports wise is
actually happening in football looked
out here at the Train a cap and Rob
Gronkowski is is touching his left hand
to his right [ __ ] cleat Rob you find
it harder to reach to the right one with
your left hand or the left one with your
right hand
I'm sorry Brock Gronkowski's not
answering questions right now I mean who
the [ __ ] is gonna sit around watch that
all right they used to at least have the
goddamn Pro Bowl they had something
going on but that's it people there's
only one more week of NFL football and
there's only two teams left all right
one left so you have to ask yourself who
are you inviting to your Super Bowl
party huh are you gonna have the balls
to [ __ ] only invite sports fans
I guess if your team isn't in it why do
you give a [ __ ] why not be social you
know what I mean
why not have a bunch of people come over
who don't give a [ __ ] they're just there
for the burgers the Doritos the [ __ ]
hot dogs the stupid dips that [ __ ]
thing that somebody made that nobody
really likes but they bring it every
year and everybody's got to take at
least one [ __ ] bite out of the thing
maybe like oh I think I'm thinking I'm
toying with the idea of having people
over it's going to be a select few all
right and they will come in in unmanned
drones and hopefully not fall through
the [ __ ] roof of my house that's what
I'm hoping that's what I'm hoping
happens now why the [ __ ] is this seems
like the sound is down low on this one
ad Jesus Christ who knows who the [ __ ]
knows I just want to thank all the brave
men and women who make the mixer's out
there who are fighting for my freedom
defending this country against terrorism
how's that dude how much longer is this
government shutdown gonna lie this is
like the most [ __ ] petty goddamn like
and I don't understand - why if the
government shuts down okay air traffic
controllers and people like that they
don't get paid but politicians continue
to get [ __ ] paid I bet I'll - I'll go
out on a limb here
I'll bet because there was some sort of
legislation that a [ __ ] politician
paid somebody to come up with and they
all [ __ ] agreed they all agreed to be
I guess we will continue to get paid
those [ __ ] filthy [ __ ] I still don't
understand how somebody could actually
be a Democrat or a Republican when you
watch behavior like this for you to
actually just [ __ ] sit there you know
I mean I don't know I'm gonna sit here
and I'm what I'm gonna do now is do what
every [ __ ] [ __ ] does which is I'm
gonna state the obvious without a
solution you know and act like I am
above you all right that's what I mean I
do that in general just part of being of
a form a part of getting on stage part
of being back and waiting for your name
to be called and feeling that rush of
excitement that can only be described as
someone else who has taken the stage you
know when you speak into a microphone
this this you just feel like you know
things all right and I apologize to all
of you poor people out there who never
in your life will you ever know the
thrill of not reading and simply turning
on a device speaking into a microphone
recording yourself you know I feel bad
for you you know I respect all of you
you know you put your pants on one leg
at a time
you know Joe six-packs you get through
at least four beers before you
physically abuse the woman in your life
you know the regular Joe's out there
lunch pail Larry right ham hock Harry
you know [ __ ] Caprice
on Sandra capri-sun where the [ __ ] did I
pull that out I don't know my name I
never got into those [ __ ] juices back
in the day all that [ __ ] weird [ __ ]
people used to eat what were those
things during lunch time thirty [ __ ]
years ago in the cafeteria I'd go to it
would literally be what they were fruit
roll-ups you said this [ __ ] fruit
roll-ups and I swear to god it looked
like wax these people would just [ __ ]
just be I don't know what it was it was
it was some sort of fruit infused flavor
with like a pound of sugar and then I
don't know earwax from [ __ ] workers
in a third-world plant or some [ __ ] I
don't know what it wasn't kids would sit
there and eat I mean you know what
nobody died nobody died and and and the
world was actually was in a lot of ways
was a better place I'm not saying we
were as progressive as we are today some
would argue overly progressive and when
I say some I would say a lot of the
voices in my head would say I think
we're going a little too far with this
[ __ ] you know when you start giving
actors [ __ ] for acting why are you
pretending to be something that you're
not because it's acting that that is
what acting is okay if you if you take
an acting job and you just act what you
already are that's not really acting
which is why so many people have done a
decent job being what they are on
sprayed and then everybody thinks they
can act oh I can act act it's easy
remember when that chick from whole that
crazy drug-addicted chick from hole
played the crazy drug-addicted chick in
that [ __ ] but she was unbelievable as
they create that crazy drug-addicted
chick I could believe oh well she played
a crazy drug-addicted chick not saying
every crazy drug-addicted woman can then
go on screen it there is a certain level
of [ __ ] talent okay but don't put
yourself on the same level that my left
foot guy the guy walks around acting
like Abe Lincoln for a [ __ ] year
before he's actually a blinkin okay then
you're gonna just come in and play
height version yourself what am i doing
right now I am describing
my acting career anyways how much time
is that oh Jesus Christ it's like [ __ ]
you know it's hilarious it's like 5:50
in the morning and I got up to go to the
gym I got a I got the acting gig also
happens today I just have a later call
time so I was like I'm gonna get up and
go to the gym alright cuz I'm trying to
get myself back in shape here right so
remember the old gym song I go to the
gym every day it's just become pop me
life and if you don't want to be a fatty
you go to the gym every day you can't
everybody so I don't go every day I take
one day off alright
I figure even if the Lord needed to take
one day off when he was creating the
universe as I'm sculpting this
flower-covered
colored body do you know how you know
something all of these minorities out
there with their pigment [ __ ] moaning
and complaining I ask you this as a
privileged white male do you understand
how difficult it is to get shredded when
you're as transparent as me okay I could
be in just as good a shape as some
Hawaiian okay but because I am so pasty
the world is never gonna know it and do
you understand how difficult that is for
me when I walk out into the world it's
like hey I have a couple of ABS too
you just can't see them I want to get
that Janet Jackson stomach makeup we
just said you know get one of those
people that you know when you almost
have abs then they just spray-paint them
in I want to do that right and then I'm
gonna do put on a half shirt and do my
dance cover of miss you much miss you
miss you much I really miss you much I
I had a crush on her when she was on
Diff'rent Strokes I didn't like her when
she was on good times you know what I
mean and not cuz she was younger with
baby fat and you know cuz we're
basically the same age it was because
she was broke okay and I'm not I'm not
trying to get with some yes she was
living in the projects then I liked her
better when she was you know on
Diff'rent Strokes you know interacting
with super rich white people then then
me as a little white kid could relate
like alright
oh now the world don't move to the beat
just one drum what my rap you may not be
right for some all right that was
inadvertently one of the funnier things
that I've said on this podcast but I'm
sure someone will take it in the wrong
way what are you saying you can't fall
in love with someone because they live
in the projects projects projects that's
exactly what I'm saying
that is how privileged I am you know if
women can go into these [ __ ] single
buys these meat markets and one of their
first questions they ask you when you
run into him is what do you do for a
living you know how much [ __ ] cake
are you putting on the table they're
swinging dick right why can't I choose
why can't I choose my TV crushes huh
that's how it was I was an elitist with
my TV crunches crushes you know [ __ ] all
those [ __ ] on the Waltons but I would
[ __ ] anybody on Falcon Crest Inc now the
world don't move to debita just one drum
bunch of rich white people throwing each
other in the pool in evening gowns I've
never seen that one is that one Joan
Crawford and Morgan Fairchild had their
infamous catfight you know I think it's
reenacted on floats during the gay pride
parade in every city isn't that what
they didn't have
tired they have to have one
stereotypical thing
all right gay people gay men let's let's
do what straight people think we're into
let's let's appease them so we can try
to be a little more mainstream this year
man that different strokes on when if
when it gets in your [ __ ] head you
just can't get it out you know but it's
enjoyable everybody's dead except that
due to played Willis that's kind of sad
I guess I die next I think I'm the same
age as Willis Willis drumming boo boo
boo with his drumming he's owned the
only one left alive guess he is yeah
that's a you know something that's what
I do when I watch me TV I try to see
like who's the only guy left oh that's a
great [ __ ] tribute thing name TV
shows where there's only one series
regular still alive Diff'rent Strokes
The Beverly Hillbillies way ain't
getting well doing well hang on when I
Wow
the [ __ ] the dude you know that's how
you right now that's how that shows you
right now how hard show businesses you
know I mean because in the real world
women outlive the men alright but this
business is so [ __ ] difficult that I
said that doesn't make any sense does it
well let's see well the one chick
overdosed and then the housekeeper she
was like 93 when they started shooting
that she [ __ ] crushed it she had a
great acting career you know she had two
shows that made syndication she was on
she was on the facts of life I you take
the good you take the bad you take them
both in there you have the facts of life
you know you know why that song was at
that tempo because when you really just
slow that down that doesn't make any
sense you take the good you take the bad
you take them both and there you have
the facts of life it's a what that
doesn't mean anything but you speed it
up take the good you take the bad you
take them both and there you have the
facts like oh that's catchy
feel like thinking the facts of life I
know what you think in a bill your wife
is black we ended Tootie on that show no
I was not I like Joe Joe the mechanic I
liked her riding the dirtbike the
[ __ ] tomboy I like Blair at first you
know at first I liked Blair but there
was just something so [ __ ] wholesome
about her after a while I was just like
at Jesus Christ I can't imagine the
[ __ ] look she'd be givin me a weekend
to this D like how I'm entertaining the
fact that a young freckled me could
actually dated Blair from Oh was that
[ __ ] show I just said it the facts of
life all right
I don't have anything to talk about so
I'm gonna tell you about my TV crushes
all right back in the day I would
occasionally watch Charlie's Angels
because even back then I was so sexist
that I couldn't get over the fact that I
was watching these women all made up
running down the alleys tackling these
[ __ ] guys into trash cans you know
having said that I obviously like Farrah
Fawcett right but I was a Kate Jackson
fan she was sort of the first to me more
I feel you know the [ __ ] brunette
with the smoky [ __ ] voice and then
the best was when she was on the rookies
bad attitude you know what I would love
to have on the [ __ ] podcast I would
love to have the trumpet player from the
1970s who [ __ ] just got in with
whatever studio and played half of those
theme songs dude if you were in a
[ __ ] horn section living in LA in the
70s right and you just [ __ ] and then
they had all those cop shows you were
working every [ __ ] with you and that
Bongo player the Bongo player was just
crushed every time you [ __ ] chase the
suspect down a [ __ ] alley they always
were playing the congas and the bongos
right and then whenever they had the
themes
for the show is the [ __ ] horn section
but up been a bad urban up trumpets
[ __ ] horn players crushing it walking
around polyester shirts with unbuttoned
down to your navel you add your
medallion your little coke Spode right
don't go to bed with a price on your
head do it alright bill what are you
predictions for the Super Bowl you know
me I never think my team's gonna win
I hope they win but I'll tell you right
now they're gonna have their heads full
of these Rams of Los Angeles that I
already make fun of those [ __ ] those
30-something douchebags who in the Rams
jerseys who are crying they're getting
all emotional and their [ __ ]
girlfriends were comforting them when
the Rams beat this a it's like what the
[ __ ] you couldn't such a typical
phony [ __ ] la douchebag it's like the
Rams have been back for three years they
left in the 80s
you're [ __ ] 30 years old you don't
remember these [ __ ] people oh my god
now the world don't move to the beat
adjust one drum your team just move back
stop with the crocodile tears that's the
wrong expression stop with your phony
[ __ ] tears those were actors that's
what they were and then the NFL of
course has to show them look how happy
we make people and now let's take a
veteran out of the crowd and charge the
Marines money for it
ladies gentlemen how about a round of
applause for this hero that we're now
charging the military fee for a
commercial acting like we support let's
bring out the American flag everybody
and [ __ ] out people's patriotism so we
can make more
let's settle this class-action suit with
former players that comes down to about
$38 per player oh Jesus I'm getting a
cynical 29 minutes we made another one
you know what I got to read a little
advertising here I could be broken my
own [ __ ] that's how I I justify
my crush my elitist crush on Janet
Jackson all right here we go
he looks everybody hellix hey man you
ever wake up in the morning with a
raging heart now you ever wake up in the
morning with regrets of what you'd done
do you know what I did this morning I
woke up this morning I had a dream that
one of my relatives was on a boat that
sank with like 200 [ __ ] people and
they were all missing and somehow I was
in the ocean but still in my house and I
found my loved one and they picked her
up and she was facedown and when I
turned her over she started crying and
was coughing and she was still alive and
I came in and I think I talked [ __ ] I
talked the other rescuers I said beat
that and then I realized she was still
alive and I started crying and then I
really just started wailing crying and I
walked by my mother and she just went
Jesus bill like I was crying too much I
don't even get supported my dreams
replaying the terrible decisions you
made the previous night over and over
and over the kicking the sweating the
yelling or whatever else you did to piss
everyone off it pissed everyone in the
bedroom off well guess what bud
depending deciding to sleep on a shitty
mattress is your choice I like how these
people try to write this dialogue like
the way I talk so now I have to take
my head away from the microphone and
read literally what they wrote well
you're in luck buddy
a lot of buds and buddy here it's
written by Jeff Spicoli what's your
problem bud because HELOCs helix sleep
the mattress I've been yelling at you to
buy for almost two years will challenge
your life just go to helix sleep calm
slash / take there two minutes sleep
quiz and they'll match you to the
perfect mattress it's like for finding a
mattress all the fun with none of the
next morning regrets and misery and
right now you can get up to 125 dollars
off your mattress order on HELOCs sleep
helix calm / / they have a 100 night
trial free shipping and won't send you
creepy text the next day
that's helix sleep calm / / for up to
125 dollars off your mattress they let
you try that you got a hundred night
free trial it doesn't feel right we
don't want our bang in my broad it just
doesn't feel right in my clock you know
well what kind of balls do you have I
got those medium sized ones but for some
reason they weigh down my ball sack as
if it's not a quality ball sack you know
like I feel like if I had a quality ball
sack the weight of my balls they
wouldn't be mid-thigh it actually makes
me know do they in plastic surgery am I
gonna see one of the male Kardashian's
go down there and get a ball tuck a ball
sack tuck you know do you have a wrinkly
ball sack that is so 2018 come on down
and get Botox keffiyeh balls Botox just
listen to what these women have to say I
never used to lick my husband's balls
down there every night taint all right
that was my nod to David Cross and Bob
Odenkirk one of the hardest I've ever
left in a sketch show is when they did
that [ __ ] sketch about the guy with
the giant taint
the porn industry and how they were it
was it was not that sketch I didn't even
hear that sketch it's the way they went
into that sketch where they had like a
Batman style fight I can't really
remember what happened but like you know
they were doing the freeze-frame
on the on the on the punches they go pow
Biff you know slam and then the last one
this dude look like he kicked the guy in
the balls and it just said taint and I
was [ __ ] screaming laughing because
taint was in the white world a very not
known reference at that point if I
remember correctly that came out of the
african-american community you know
taint [ __ ] tape balls
it's the taint right and that was new to
white people and I was not ready for I
think Patrice told me that one and I
wasn't ready for that
to be coming out of that show and I was
screaming laughing and my lady at the
time who was Caucasian she didn't know
what I was laughing at but I was left
you know when somebody laughed so hard
even if you don't get it you start laugh
and that's basically what happened and
you know what just happened there you
just listen to 34 minutes of my [ __ ]
I got you again [ __ ] all right
that's the podcast have a great weekend
you [ __ ] there's gonna be a little
musical interlude here and then you're
gonna listen to another 30 minutes of my
greatest hits Thursday afternoon just
before Friday Monday morning podcast
possibly released on Saturday they made
a night it came out 10 years ago eight
years ago or [ __ ] eight minutes ago I
don't know I don't pick them alright
I'll see you on Monday
good morning what's going on it's bill
burr it's the Monday morning podcast for
Monday January 24th 2011 how the hell
are you
how you doing did you have a good week
was the world nice to you this is a big
day for me everybody this is my 100th
day remember when I said I was knocking
off the booze cuz I was starting to have
a big bloated face I was like [ __ ] this
I got a I got a you know got to get on
the treadmill I got a knock off the
booze and I was trying to beat my
previous record of going 75 days and
this time I said [ __ ] and I'm going for
an even hundred and the goal has been
acheived James I'm psyched I did it and
tonight I'm going to the Bruins LA Kings
game down at this table feta the most
unfriendly fan [ __ ] place you'll ever
go to
it's the haves the really Habs and the
half nuts I've broken it down for you
before you got all the corporate seats
down low sitting next Dyan Cannon Jack
Nicholson and [ __ ] [ __ ] Spacek
whoever the [ __ ] else is down there all
those douchebags sitting there with
their [ __ ] faces yanked back you know
by the way how long is Jack Nicholson
been going bald for it's just [ __ ]
unbelievable how long it took for that
guy to go bald he lost one hair a day
since 1972 Sonny have you noticed that
there's certain people it just takes for
[ __ ] ever unless they seamlessly went
into a toupee but he's bald now but you
know being someone who's balding myself
you know I pay attention to that type of
[ __ ] and I pay attention to all these
[ __ ]
I see the receding hairline and all of a
sudden it's not there the next movie and
I was like there you go look at that guy
he went out and he got himself sort of
scalped in a user-friendly way and then
they receded the front I going out like
that my goal in life I want to look like
Clint Howard
oh it's not gonna end good for me
yes I went a hundred days 100 days 100
days and yes and I don't know I'm afraid
I'm scared everyone I'm afraid to start
drinking again because I noticed that I
just pick up where I left off like I
really learned about addiction during
these last hundred days I realized how
much [ __ ] I was you know not addicted to
to a level that it was like you know I
was coming home and slapping my girl
around you know getting on all fours
growling at my dog as I peed on the
stereo and then the next morning like I
didn't do it I don't remember that well
maybe I would drink if you weren't such
a [ __ ] you know I wasn't doing stuff
like that that was just out having a
good [ __ ] time I like beer the way I
like cake and cookies there's really no
reason there's no reason to have cake or
cookies there's no nourishment that your
body needs you don't need that much
[ __ ] sugar but I like it I like the
[ __ ] rush you know you sitting there
feeling gloomy yeah I hate myself what
am i doing remember when I was young and
I just go out and play frisbee and it
was fun man it was simple right you get
older you got all this debt you get
those [ __ ] everybody's [ __ ] nag
and you you get the blues so you go out
you got a slice of cake right feeling
like [ __ ] six bites of cake later you're
like dude I am [ __ ] awesome right you
got that sugar rush going so that's what
I realized I am I have a number of
addictions I am addicted to sugar not
like a you know I need an intervention
but like I [ __ ] crave it but if I lay
off it for four days when if I don't eat
any sweets for four [ __ ] days when I
look at a doughnut or a piece of cake
it's like laughable like why the [ __ ]
would you eat that look at it yet that
that that that it doesn't even look like
real food you know when you're off when
you're [ __ ] when you've kicked sugar
when you look at a glazed doughnut just
sitting there all [ __ ] sweaty
it just looks horrible it's like why
would you do that to you so you know you
look at all the frosting on a cake you
you make that face like you just sucked
on a lemon like Jesus Christ
enough already that [ __ ] [ __ ]
downstairs just slam the door cuz I'm
being too loud I don't care
douchebag I [ __ ] love old people but
I hate that [ __ ] downstairs I
[ __ ] hate that guy
I hate that he's got that classic old
person smell he doesn't he has a unique
smell you know what he's son he smells
like a like a [ __ ] if you lit a wet
dog on fire okay if you did that that's
what he smells like [ __ ] miserable
[ __ ]
there's goddamn Dockers the original
Dockers [ __ ] army-navy store shop and
douche bag [ __ ] miserable [ __ ] giving
me the stink out every time I walk up
the [ __ ] walk I can't stand the guy
[ __ ] hate him there I hate him I
don't give a [ __ ]
alright I die I'll [ __ ] you know I'll
argue that one in the afterlife I'll sit
right there you know you drank it drove
yes I did guilty as charged
and treated a lot of women like [ __ ]
you're absolutely right guilty as
charged
and you had a you had a poor opinion
about the old man downstairs well let me
tell you something Jesus you try living
above that [ __ ] [ __ ]
go talk to your dad he made him oh shut
up you [ __ ] hippie oh jeez
so anyways so tonight I am going to I'm
gonna go watch the best of the of the of
the four sports the four major sports
hockey is the best goddamn sport out
there alright and I know a lot of you
won't realize that because you never
played it you never went to a game hence
you don't know what you're talking about
you know it'd be like me making fun of
line
I've never done it you know I've never
gone out and bought a pair of Wrangler
jeans that were [ __ ] eight dollars
and nine so they cupped my [ __ ] balls
and got out there and stuck my hands in
my pockets and did this little [ __ ]
that little oh my god that [ __ ] line
dancing
can there be a mass suicide amongst line
dancers could that just [ __ ] happen
in the middle of one of your [ __ ]
corn ball stupid ass [ __ ] so country
music it country music is I don't even
know what it's for it's for like pod
people there's absolutely no soul in it
what so it there isn't all right there
angry redneck listening to this punching
the dashboard of your chevy s-10 all
right there isn't it [ __ ] sucks and
that line dancing we sit there with your
[ __ ] thumbs in your [ __ ] pocket
and you do that little I'm doing I'm
actually I'm in Dallas Texas this week
so let's let's go for big air on this
one we do that thing you [ __ ] I wish
I wish this was a vodcast which I'm not
doing by the way so stop [ __ ] asking
me the great thing about this thing is
you can listen to it while you're doing
other [ __ ] right are you or are you not
doing other [ __ ] right now well alright
then are you or are you not pretending
to be working right now looking at
spreadsheets right you want a [ __ ]
plane huh
what are your choices for food aren't
you doing that as you listen to this
well then quit your [ __ ] bitching
alright so anyways they do that stupid
thing where they ban their [ __ ] nice
and and I can't even think of the
[ __ ] music right okay okay okay right
there's none other music goes and then
they do that little thing where they
just one of them one of their feet
alright the right foot will say the
right foot it's just pivoting on the
heel and the toes of face forward and
then to the side and then back to the
front ah
then they do that little thing where
they bring their [ __ ] foot up and
they spank the bottom of their foot all
of them
yo kills me about those people is they
actually think that Jesus loves them I
Got News for you red
Jesus is looking the other way he's
embarrassed he's combing his [ __ ]
hair into his face when he watches you
people line dance he is looking like
that chick in the ring yeah speaking of
which I'm gonna be I completely forgot
what the [ __ ] I was talking about I know
yeah I'm going to go into the hockey
game tonight LA Kings first the Boston
Bruins the LA Kings which who actually
have a really good team I like that I
like that dude Simmons [ __ ] fastest
health and Koba
that's the greatest [ __ ] game and
I've actually been playing hockey
recently ice hockey the real [ __ ]
deal and I'm excited guess what I
learned how to do this week 42 years of
age not married no kids
I learned finally learned how to stop on
both sides but you know it's funny I
have I have to go buy some more hockey
stuff you know it's funny out here in LA
I have to drive all the way down to like
Orange County just to find some place
that will sell hockey stuff but I have
to even though I suck at this sport I
just I'm just an old man and like it
takes about four days that's how deep
the bruises are after I'm done falling
on the ice and like four days after I
play I look like I've been beaten with a
[ __ ] bamboo cane
I had a brutal one when I was in [ __ ]
Atlantic City last weekend doing the
Miami Heat tour of comedy by the way
Atlantic City was so successful I just
got an email today for an offer up in
Foxwoods for April 30th so I will let
you know as soon as I find out I might
actually have an update right now
wouldn't that be amazing right here on
the fly as you listen to the Monday
morning Park let's just keep the flow of
this podcast going I think this was good
I think it's what's gonna it's gonna be
a good one we're almost 11 minutes in
things are going well for some reason
the voice seems way too loud on this
thing what's going on with this anyways
yeah so I fell on my [ __ ] right ass
cheek and hip last time we played before
Atlantic City and
one lousy house I kept pushing on it go
and I can't believe that didn't bruise
it hurts when I touch it
when I push my thumb into my little
[ __ ] right butt cheek it hurts right
and then like four days later I'm in
Atlantic City and I'm showering and I
looked out and it looked like somebody
threw a can of grape soda at me so I
will be getting all of the hockey stuff
which I really didn't want to do because
I don't want to put it out there that I
think I know how to play hockey cuz I
don't I just enjoy it
it's [ __ ] fun it's a fast game the
only equipment I wear is I wear a helmet
for my big [ __ ] head and I wear the
full cage in the front because I don't
need any hockey scars you know with the
sticks and all that [ __ ] why would I do
that to myself
you know like I'm gonna win a cup and I
need this sacrifice oh speaking of which
I should probably wear a cup too right
no liftin hang on a second we're going
to the Inbox did I get anything did I
get anything nothing you [ __ ]
so anyways yeah so this so tonight
actually Tech technically I can start
boozing this is the 100th day but I got
to be honest with you I'm not gonna do
it I think I'm gonna try to see how long
I can go with this I'm gonna wait till
there is enough there is a specific
event where boozing makes sense and then
I'm gonna knock it off then I'm gonna
booze
maybe people what am i what am I gonna
do honestly am I never gonna have a beer
for the rest of my life I don't know how
those people in AAA do it that's like I
am a weird sort of like respect for
people in AAA and I also have a disdain
for them because I went to a couple of
AAA meetings not by choice
the judge told me I had to go as part of
your sentence and I went there and yeah
I didn't like it I kind of liked it I
liked sort of the room but kind of like
the only aspect of church that I like I
like going to church because it reminds
me
not to be a complete piece of [ __ ] but
other than that all that stuff about
hippies walking on water talking to
bushes it just sounds like an acid trip
and it just it's just stupid and there's
always a [ __ ] leper how many [ __ ]
lepers were there back then Jesus Christ
can't tell me he wouldn't have a [ __ ]
giant stick back in the day just for the
lepers you know
oh Jesus Christ said [ __ ] smash him
right there get the [ __ ] away from me
you [ __ ] Leopard what would Jesus do
he has the ability to cure himself I
don't all right
don't you think that that maybe that's
why he was such a good [ __ ] because he's
the son of God he knows he's going to
heaven
of course he's doing the right thing
it's it's so [ __ ] easy
to be a good [ __ ] when you can walk on
water and touch something and it gets
cured of course he's going up and
shaking your hand you [ __ ] freak get
away from me I can't do that
you're a leper [ __ ] off now go cry to
the son of God
so anyways yes I would go to these these
these meetings these meetings and you
know I don't know I I believe in
addiction and then other times I just
thinks I don't think all those people
addicts I think some of them they're
just weak I can't stop myself it's like
you don't have like your brain tells
your arm to move and pick up something
and put it to your lips
right did you guys like alcoholics you
guys become like such an alcoholic like
the bottles actually talking to you that
[ __ ] you know
god damn [ __ ] [ __ ] alcoholics all
right
go drink a case of beer I understand it
puke it up all right and then take you
know a week or two of you don't do it
every night you know
full of [ __ ] I i 100% believe in that
addiction thing and I actually believe
I'm actually now I now understand after
watching The Biggest Loser every season
I now realize yeah it is it is an
addiction because every one of those
people has some sort of psychological
reason as to why they do it but wait a
minute I'm not fat but I'm out of my
[ __ ] mind yeah yeah so [ __ ] them
alright alright sorry I had to work that
out [ __ ] those fat [ __ ] thank [ __ ] them
I get fat and then I eat 24 cakes well
nobody gets sad and they do sit-ups
what's the deal with working out
actually some people do and that's one
of the last shows they'll do Jim
addictions you know they'll do something
like that because I think they're out of
boring jobs too trying to make exciting
have you seen that they actually have a
show out there right now about people
mining for gold you know I mean mining
for gold obviously they still do it but
it's like big business now they have
these sophisticated machines that cut
the tops off of mountains and then they
grind them down like you did with you a
number two pencil in second grade trying
to get down to the eraser right okay but
nobody with a big bushy beard is
squatting down like a Chinese gambler
next to a [ __ ] river with the goddamn
dinner plate trying to find gold but lo
and behold they found 10 douchebags who
were doing it and they decided to make
it a show and they decided to [ __ ]
have what film these guys arguing each
other and play this something dangerous
is happening music underneath it and I'm
sick of it alright [ __ ] miners [ __ ]
people who make cakes for a living
did [ __ ] those goddamn crab fishermen
you know nobody is making you go on that
goddamn boat
[ __ ] idiots going out there risking
your lives of a flounder you know just
say what you do out loud for a living
just say
loud a couple of times to yourself I go
on a [ __ ] tugboat okay
and I ice I risk my life to get to get
king crabs so rich people have something
crunchy to eat
go [ __ ] yourself JPMorgan you want crab
go get it yourself
what are you [ __ ] options actually
know some I'll make it fun I actually
respect those guys cuz I have a
tremendous tremendous fear of the ocean
a huge fear people who go out and swim
in the ocean you're out of your [ __ ]
minds you're out of your [ __ ] minds
I know I've said this before in the
podcast but you know what I'm gonna say
it again I don't give a [ __ ] I'm edgy
I'm crazy they should make a show about
me and my podcast and the dangers of it
you know and then me and Neal will have
fake arguments you know we'll have [ __ ]
like plugs or something will go wrong
you know I don't know I don't have what
wins my Olympus LS Ted I thought you
were gonna have it then they'll cut to
me you know so I went to go do the
podcast and I couldn't find the Olympus
LS ten you know I mean I got to get this
podcast done by Monday or at the book
that if you notice that like I think
that Orange County Choppers they
basically created the template for all
those reality shows and now everybody
does that [ __ ] the exact same thing that
would happen on that [ __ ] motorcycle
show with it where the Sun would be like
and then we had a problem he the
carburetor didn't fit well the
carburetor wasn't here and then the ball
like then the dad comes say yo I was
going on the carburetor isn't here we're
in the carburetor
and then he gets on there so Mikey's
[ __ ] scared around I warn you with a
[ __ ] carburetor is how [ __ ] jacked
is the dad on that show he could squeeze
my entire family too
if he got excited enough um so now they
do that [ __ ] like it makes sense on the
chopper show right a bunch of mechanics
they are they're wearing their greasy
Dickies they got butt cracks hangin out
death they're gonna yell and scream at
each other right
but the [ __ ] idiots making cakes so
we get a job we have to make a cake for
the firehouse and I decided to do a cake
that was shaped like a fire hydrant I
wanted to do a fire hydrant motif with
the little Dalmatian
you know peeing on the fire hydrant but
Michael was like I don't think that we
should bring urine into something that's
gonna be in your mouth it was typical
Michael just [ __ ] on my creative
process
I'll kill yourselves nobody cares nobody
cares about you and your [ __ ] cakes
and I like cakes yeah do you guys didn't
know that about me did you let's see how
will you with 20 minutes in here 20
minutes into the [ __ ] podcast should
I do it should I do it
I'm gonna be a class act here my
condolences to the Chicago Bear fans and
the fans in the New York Jets they're
the true fans the true sports fans the
ones that don't talk [ __ ] the ones who
are cool
the ones who you you know you can
actually have a conversation about
football with my condolences go out to
you believe me as a fan of Boston teams
for my entire life I know what it feels
like to be that [ __ ] close and they
get kicked in the seeds again so my
condolences congratulations to the
Steelers and the Green Bay Packers and I
would like to open this dialogue this is
something that bugs me about NFL
football is is this I don't get why in
every other [ __ ] major sport they
count championships from a hundred years
ago like let's look at the Red Sox they
won the championship in like 1908 or
something when they had Crazy Legs McGee
was playing [ __ ] third-base with his
giant Ibanez or [ __ ] mustache they
count those the Red Sox count
five World Series titles that we went
from 1918 and before [ __ ] montreal
canadiens they count Stanley Cups that
they won during that time - all right
the Yankees they count all their pre
Depression era
during the Depression or whatever that's
right when they started winning they
count all of those the [ __ ] Celtics
count there's from the 60s the [ __ ]
Lakers count their championships their
first two or three it wasn't even the
NBA
those are BBA championships their first
four out of five championships were one
before the 24-second shot clock even
existed when you could win a basketball
game like seventeen to twelve they count
those so my question for spots for
sports fans
is this why don't they count NFL
championships why do they only count
Super Bowls because when you just count
Super Bowls the Pittsburgh Steelers are
the Yankees that Canadians they're the
celtics of football but is [ __ ] it's
[ __ ] [ __ ] because the Green Bay
Packers have won like 12 or 13 NFL
titles and Super Bowls they've won three
Super Bowls in like another eight or
nine NFL titles that for some reason
they don't count the pittsburgh steelers
were in the NFL
when Green Bay was winning all those
titles so they had a shot at winning
them you know it's as much as I give the
Canadian [ __ ] going out you dominated a
16 League which isn't really true they
were going tit-for-tat with the Maple
Leafs until 67 but the Bruins were in
that original six so we should have
dominated and we didn't so that's why I
shut the [ __ ] up when it comes to that
conversation so can anybody out there
tell me why don't they count NFL titles
like I I don't I don't get that I don't
get it that would be if you didn't count
then in baseball you would have missed
out on Babe Ruth Mickey Mantle Joe
DiMaggio none of that none of that would
count Bill Russell wouldn't count it's
[ __ ] up I think it's [ __ ]
and I think it's I think the other I
want to go to I love sports history I
want to go to an Eagles game and I want
to see 1960 NFL champions and I'm not
giving an Eagles fan [ __ ] I'm just they
should have that up there the Cleveland
Browns want it and like I don't like 63
or 64 with Jim Brown the Bears won one
with Mike Mike Ditka and what's-his-face
their Dick Butkus right
they wanted the Green Bay Packers won a
few then the Colts with Johnny Unitas
you know the ones that they won the
greatest game ever [ __ ] played Yankee
Stadium Giants first the Colts 1958 the
overtime [ __ ] victory right they don't
count any of that [ __ ] it's it's
disrespectful to the athletes that
played those were the best of the best
at least white guys for most of those
yet but seriously there was only one
professional league so the talent pool
was even greater then and they they
don't they don't count it and I think
it's [ __ ] [ __ ] and I'm hoping that
somebody talks about that considering
you have the most successful team since
the Super Bowl era and then you have
playing the most successful team in NFL
history they have won in every era
except for the 70s and 80s I guess they
didn't win a championship in the 2008
but they but they've been competitive or
whatever you know I don't know speaking
of which you know do you guys realize
that right now Brett Favre
is getting sued sort of this [ __ ] this
is how [ __ ] up the world is right now
Brett Favre
is getting sued by the by two masseuses
because he tried to get some sort of
sexual favors afterwards and they're
they're suing for that do you understand
that let me say that just one more time
Brett Favre is getting sued by a
masseuse to masseuses said I said
masseuse says mooses
to masseuses for for asking basically to
uh you know to bang him at the end of it
they're suing him can you [ __ ]
believe it I just it's [ __ ] bus that
would you know what that's like that's
like me suing a comedy club because I
got heckled it comes with the job there
is not any masseuse any female masseuse
out there that listens to this podcast
are you honestly gonna tell me that she
that you've been rubbing guys backs and
their legs in the chest and all that and
you've no one has ever asked you for a
[ __ ] hand job at the end of it it
[ __ ] comes with the territory that's
like being a cop and sue in the city cuz
you got shot at all right you [ __ ]
put hot oil all over a guy's body and
you rub everything but their dick I mean
give me a [ __ ] break
you goddamn [ __ ] teases yeah people are
gonna ask you to rub one out okay and if
you had a shred of [ __ ] decency you
do it you complete the goddamn job
alright because your sign says full body
massage alright
last I saw my dick is still part of my
body all right you know what the hell
you know what masseuses are like they
like the [ __ ] quarterback who can't
get it done you know
just always comes up a little bit short
they should [ __ ] interview him
afterwards so you know like what
happened in there yeah you know I just
didn't just didn't get it done you know
it was like right there all I do is just
reach out and grab it and I just you
know we didn't want it we didn't want it
as much as they wanted it
that's just like just that's such a
classic piggyback lawsuit it's like once
that first stupid [ __ ] you know gave
Brett Favre [ __ ] this is very
interesting that I've noticed about
horse once one comes out of the woodwork
then all of a sudden twenty come out of
the woodwork you know and then they
always try to paint it as well we were
too scared we were scared [ __ ] you
you were you're trying to make money
and you're trying to build on a momentum
of the other case that's the female
version of pulling a train on somebody
you know the guy version is you know you
an 80 of friends bang the same girl the
female version is you know you're a
[ __ ] [ __ ] and you're just waiting
for a [ __ ] to sue a guy that you
[ __ ] banked and then you [ __ ] you
draft in right behind their lawsuit okay
like one of those [ __ ] fairies that
rides in that bike race out there in in
in France that just pissed some people
off actions you realize that the level
of cardial that you need to compete in
that sport is ten times that of a
professional hockey player that's when
you know you're watching a sport that no
one gives a [ __ ] about when you have to
really start bringing out like science
they did a study the heart rate of the
average highlight player oh go [ __ ]
yourself why don't you take that
highlight thing and just [ __ ] cup
your nuts you taint in your [ __ ] and
carry yourself out of here why don't you
do that does that make sense is that
what they do with the highlight sticks
or is it shaped that way it's sort of a
you know a user friendly bike seats that
you can rock up and down on you know I
think it's time to read some questions
for this week I'm gonna say I have
exhausted all improv skills at this
point Oh first thing I want to tell you
guys can you guys do me a huge favor if
you're on Facebook there's some
douchebag pretending to be me on
Facebook just don't add the guy he has a
Celtics logo I don't know what he's
doing he's not doing anything malicious
he's just pretending to be me and it's
really weirding me out I mean I don't
know what he thinks he's good I mean I
can't get laid off of Facebook so I
don't know what this well maybe he's got
better typing game than I do you know
but I just don't want that [ __ ] to be
added to my file down there in Houston
you know all right there's a lot of
question out there about you know things
that happen within society especially
you know this this is something that I
think a lot of white people need
not because we're more racist than
anybody else we just get just the the
consequences of us [ __ ] up is so much
harsher than other people because you
know we are the gold standard when it
comes to racist we are in the driver's
seat right now we have been in the
driver's seat for a while basically
meaning that if we are ignorant [ __ ]
it has way more effect than when other
people are you know back in the day when
other people were running [ __ ] that's
the thing whoever's on top if you're
thinking ignorant that's what that's why
you know if you're on top and you're
thinking ignorant [ __ ] you have to be
called on it because just because he cuz
the effect that you can have you don't
have made like if somebody from
Bangladesh [ __ ] hates me that's such
a stupid example okay that that's not a
race of people I think we know our
Bangladesh is and I gotta be honest with
you I don't even know if that's a city
or a country Bangladesh have ever seen
that on the price is right you know a
showcase showdown we're selling you to
Bangladesh and some white trash person
like myself sister with the confused
look on their face like I don't know
where that is is that with a terrorist
star I don't want to go there whatever
like a Filipino people [ __ ] hate me
that doesn't affect my life it doesn't
I'm not gonna go into a job interview
and you know Walmart is not run by
Filipinos you know I mean you know not
saying there's anything wrong Filipinos
All Right see what see what have to do
it there's a white person not say I'm
saying I do bad about Filipino
just be clear here plant I have never
had issues I don't have a lab of Gotham
I'll [ __ ] all that [ __ ] you gotta go
to the Jerry Lewis voice there lady so
yeah people have questions so here we go
and I think all races to chime in the
questions that you have if you have
feelings about a different race of
people and you just think out you're
thinking something funny there's nothing
malicious but is this offensive is it
racist this is this is the new topic
okay and if you feel that I answer these
questions like the ignorant white man
that I am call me out on it here so here
we go this
bill is it racist to call Indians did
Davos and I'm talking about the Asian
ones not Native Americans I'm guessing
by Debbie Davos you mean dooba dooba
dooba dooba the baby the bull you're
saying like that
Debbie Dabu is it racist probably but
it's [ __ ] funny so that knocks it
down a little bit this is what I feel
that makes something like racist it's
like like the reason why that one isn't
as offensive is because we haven't we
never enslaved them that's the reason
why white and black should is so
sensitive is because of the [ __ ] that we
did to him but we haven't really [ __ ]
with those people you know so if the
black version of that was is it is it
offensive to call black people hate
[ __ ] or whatever yes that would
be offensive if you did some sort of
mocking of the way they spoke yes that
would be that would be offensive some
CEO was giving a speech and I was
driving actually I was having someone
else drive my town car and we drove by a
group of and they proceeded to walk for
us yes you'd have to apologize so I
guess yeah I guess technically do madaba
like that would be that would be
offensive is it racist this is what I
really really it's hard for me to say
because it had it's what's in your heart
you know because I make [ __ ] I really I
make fun of everybody you know I mean I
play a game out here when someone is
make let me ask you I got a question for
you is this racist I have a game out
here when I ride around with Nia and she
does not approve of this to keep her in
the clear she does not approve this when
somebody makes a moronic move in front
of me you know driving you know just
makes a [ __ ] horrific move I play a
game called old or Asian
and you have to guess when cuz I'm gonna
pass the person cuz I got to see what
they look like
you know whenever somebody does
something [ __ ] up some comedians do
great joke about that you just want to
see what the [ __ ] they look like right
that's the game older Asian so as I
speed up my little hybrid to try to pull
parallel to them I always said what do
you say Nia what are you going with
older Asian what he got older Asian she
goes I'm not playing this game that's
mean and then I was gonna go with old
and then I pull up oh it's [ __ ] Asian
you know we're all I nailed it it was an
old guy so is that racist
I'm sure it's offensive but within the
context of my own car you know I'm not
yelling it at anybody and I got to admit
you know there's a lot of truth in the
[ __ ] game yeah Jesus I'm gonna have
to apologize next week on the podcast so
I would say that Indian people why don't
you chime in I would say that yeah that
they would find that they would find
that offensive is it racist let me see
if I can use it in a sentence here hey
you know I called up customer service
and you know one of those new bird
dollars answered and tried to tell me
that his name was Steve and act like he
was in Kentucky but I I know that he was
actually in India because what he talked
to you but going double-double would how
could I help you is it racist probably
you know what something bad has to
happen between white culture and or
Western culture and Indians so you know
what I mean it's like it's like you're
playing a team and there's no rivalry
like Patriots versus Jeff this year was
like whites and blacks it was bad it was
a lot of hate you know but like Patriots
verse like the [ __ ] Lions you know
yeah there's gonna be some [ __ ] targets
it's knocked down but it still hurts if
somebody says something mean
I don't I really know what the [ __ ] I'm
talking about alright let's move to the
next one the next one on the new
controversial topic on the Monday
morning podcast is it racist all right
here we go
bill I had an interesting experience
today apparently involving me as a
racist I was walking with two of my
co-workers who are both black oh geez
here we go we were going to go get some
lunch one of my co-workers who almost
friends with did a little high-five fist
bump with one of the female sex security
guards at the front desk knowing both of
them and how they interact with one
another I kind of made a in passing
comment to the tune of man you guys in
your handshakes while obviously laughing
laughing while obviously laughing at
just how choreographed it was and more
or less picturing them in a studio or
something working out the logistics to
get the [ __ ] handshake perfect
anyways we all laughed and moved on and
we got our lunch
alright so nothing wrong yet so you're
cool with these people you made a joke
and everybody laugh no problems no
problem so far um however after coming
back through secured back through
security I noticed the security guard
stopped me and kind of had a scowl on
her face I thought she was mad at me for
something but it turned out she was mad
at this other lady who was black because
she overheard my comment and was telling
that security guard that she couldn't
believe I had the nerve to say something
like that and I should be ashamed also
to the point where she could almost to
the point where she could actually go
complain to the human resource people
because she was offended etc without
even considering that maybe just maybe I
was talking about the security guard and
my coworker and not all black people now
it being corporate America and all I'm
sure rather than even face the
possibility of any bad press
they'd rather just sweep me out the door
and completely ruin my Rennie reputation
I may or may not hold at the company
just to save their own asses I feel I
did nothing wrong
and had no intentions of ever doing
anything wrong or anything wrong I'm not
going to go on and on about how I kiss
black babies and trying to rehabilitate
inner-city schools because I don't but
I'm certainly not some corn-fed rebel
flag-waving
ignorant product of what might be incest
I guess my question is do we really have
to walk on eggshells when we are just
making casual conversation that just any
that just any [ __ ]
select the context that they might think
it is in and then start crying foul
basically I would have liked to call
that woman a [ __ ] and told her to go
[ __ ] herself but let's just say I was
already kind of worried about my job All
Right see ya I think this is this is the
classic one where you were [ __ ]
around the other two people knew you
were [ __ ] around but then one person
just decides to get offended and then
you have to go on TV and apologize which
personally I think is the wrong move
because when you apologize now it's like
you're admitting that you meant it in a
bad way I mean the apology I would do
they'd say look you know I'm sorry that
you didn't understand that I was joking
but I'm not gonna say to her and
apologize like I have any any sort of
ill-will coming your way you know but I
but just to avoid the problem in the
future
white people do not use the expression
you guys or you people when talking
about black people that's just it it's
just not gonna be you're setting
yourself up for someone to get offended
and there's a weird sort of push-pull
going on with that whole you guys and
you people think we're when somebody
white says that there becomes this
concern of that you're separating
you're separating like yeah you know you
people over there with how you live your
lives and we're over here black people
have that weird relationship with white
people where they're like you know can
you stop stealing our [ __ ] music and
our culture and but then like if
something you know hey let's pay the
streets you know well make sure you do
it in our neighborhood we're all in this
together right all of us together you
know what I mean
so that's that weird sort of [ __ ]
push-pull thing going on so yeah just
avoid avoid the whole [ __ ] yeah you
[ __ ] up you didn't [ __ ] up but you you
left yourself open for a sucker punch by
saying you guys you know that's I guess
that that's what it is I don't know
that's that's that's my I'm basically a
white guy telling a white guy how he
[ __ ] up so black people if you
listening to this thing please please
help me out here did I basically get it
right is that essentially it and I know
most people wouldn't get offended but
that's one of those things like that
girl getting offended and then you got
to worry that you're gonna lose your job
it's like those [ __ ] pinky back
[ __ ] who massage guys for a living you
know some of those masseuses they'll
actually come to your house and give you
a full-body rubdown with oil okay and
then have the [ __ ] nerve to get upset
that you try to get a hand jump at the
end of it you know give me a [ __ ]
break why don't you [ __ ] masseuse
broads man the [ __ ] up and start rubbing
one out is it that goddamn hard no pun
intended is it that [ __ ] difficult to
just [ __ ] you know it's like you're
revving a motorcycle that's it that's
all you gotta do up and down up and down
with that dead [ __ ] oil you in and
out you want that house on the hill
sweetheart there's a price to pay all
right
and when a quarterback who owns every
[ __ ] record good and bad in the
goddamn universe asked you to rub one
out goddamn it you [ __ ] rub one out
well maybe you don't blog in this
business
that's right stare at your [ __ ]
manicured toes pedicured whatever the
[ __ ] you're supposed to say um Jesus
Christ mean-spirited alright so there
you go that's the nude that's the new
topic is it racist and I would love to
hear some honest comments from non white
people about their thoughts you know the
[ __ ] up ones - okay cuz I've watched
enough Spike Lee movies to think that
evidently it's just us but I've hung
around enough people from different
races to realize oh yeah everybody's
like this everybody has their little
[ __ ] up thoughts you guys ever seen
that Broadway play they got that song
everybody everyone's a little bit racist
what is that the alphabet city one
whenever the [ __ ] it's called I actually
enjoyed that actually went to a Broadway
musical
and there was puppets in it and I had a
great time how about that what does that
say about me
alright let's get on with advice advice
for this week
all right advice bill let me set this
one up for you cuz it gets a little
complicated over there I went to a New
Year's Eve party with my best friend of
13 years old Jesus oh by the way this
guy uses so many [ __ ] names I'm just
gonna use the names all right I know I
don't name names but [ __ ] this guy
there's like 15 [ __ ] names and then
he goes back to the first name back to
the seventh name so [ __ ] it I'm naming
names alright so here we go I'm
suspending that rule much like they
suspended the salary cap an NFL football
this year same way all right
all right bill I went to a New Year's
Eve party with my best friend of 13
years mock I got really drunk and hooked
up with my friend Jon's
ex-girlfriend Anna John and Anna had
dated for two years John broke up with
Anna back in September rather harshly
and immediately started banging other
girls Anna and I also worked together Oh
geesh
and we've become good friends here we go
so hooking up seemed inevitable our
friends have even joked about it hey if
you guys like [ __ ] each other yet you
guys want to get wings anyway I have
been dating the
girl Sara since October we never got to
serious we kind of agreed to take a
break when she left to go to London for
spring semester max girlfriend who
happened to be a [ __ ] his best friends
with Sarah all right are you like me are
you already lost are there too many
[ __ ] names here let's go back to the
beginning mark and I got really drunk no
I went to a New Year's Eve party with my
best friend Mark I got really drunk and
hooked up with okay Mark's his friend
John has the ex girlfriend all right
it's like a [ __ ] miniseries I had to
show you clips from last week
so anyways he's dating some [ __ ] named
Sarah they agreed to take a break and
the girl you taking a break with is best
friends with your friend's girlfriend
mark okay I got it all right I'm up to
speed here so at this party Anna and I
this is John's ex and and I get pretty
drunk and start making out none of our
friends were there except for Mac Mac
saw it and got upset you [ __ ] [ __ ]
and just had to leave oh my god really
like some fifteen-year-old girl exactly
Anna and I went to her place and
proceeded to do some stuff we didn't
bang that night but oral sex and whatnot
was traded and we passed out we both
agreed that nobody needed to know what
happened I went to Mark's house later
New Year's Day and said nothing happened
with Anna and I Anna and I and by the
way we just made out I figured that was
enough for him to know not to tell
anyone especially his [ __ ] girlfriend
neither of us brought it up for the next
four days and it seemed like everything
was fine a couple of days past out of
nowhere Mark asked me if I was going to
tell John that Anna and I made out I was
sort of taken aback as you should have
been sort of taken aback by the question
but I told him I hadn't planned on it he
said he wouldn't tell John if I didn't
because he didn't want to
a bad friend all right good man I told
him that it wasn't a big deal that we
just made out and he was being a huge
[ __ ] that was a bad move on your part
even though he was being a huge [ __ ] he
shouldn't have said that
all right because he's acting like a
[ __ ] chick right here and hell hath
no fury like a woman scorned and you
just scorned that [ __ ] [ __ ] man
right there alright so you can guess
where the [ __ ] this is going okay and
then asked him if he told his girlfriend
about it and of course he said yes when
I asked him why the [ __ ] he did that he
said because I needed to know if I
should tell John Jesus Christ I
proceeded to call him a [ __ ] good man
and let him know how much of a [ __ ]
move it was to tell his girlfriend
especially since he acted like
everything was fine for four days yeah
this guy is beyond a [ __ ] this is the
kind of guy who like you know does he
like bake brownies see one of those guys
who like doesn't mind going shopping
with his [ __ ] girlfriend yeah it's
funny that I just said that I actually
I'll bake brownies in a [ __ ] second
such a [ __ ] hypocrite alright let's
finish this alright nobody needed to
know about what happened and now he told
his girlfriend Sarah this isn't my fault
once again he [ __ ] up the sentence
nobody needs to know about what happened
and now he told his girlfriend Sarah
would definitely find out I knew Sarah
wouldn't care about me drunkenly hooking
up with Anna but it's still something
she didn't need to know
Oh Sarah's the [ __ ] [ __ ] who went to
Europe somehow I was able to leave mocs
house without beating the [ __ ] out of
him I called John who was spending
winter break in El Paso and told him
once what happened he said he didn't
really give a [ __ ] and agreed it was
[ __ ] up for Mark to say anyone
anything to anyone especially his
girlfriend when I told mark he could
have asked anyone else about whether or
not his [ __ ] ass should tell John what
happened he said he asked his girlfriend
so he could get a serious opinion as if
being told to keep your [ __ ] mouth
shut you little girl from either one of
you either one of our 10 or so close guy
friends wouldn't have been serious
enough opinion anyways I just needed
your validation on how much
[ __ ] mark was about the whole thing
also Anna and I decided to start
sneaking around and are banging each
other no harm no foul
feel free to add on to the story a
million you read any podcast yeah dude
yeah that's yeah that guy right there at
that guy you need to cut out of the loop
okay that is um that's it you you
forfeited your [ __ ] guy card it's
over you can't be trusted you think like
a woman which is fine there's nothing
wrong with thinking like a woman but
just go hang out with a bunch of women
now what a [ __ ] aah do the amount of
[ __ ] that has gone down that I have
[ __ ] I have so buried in me that I
don't even remember it the Mount of
[ __ ] [ __ ] is ridiculous and I don't
even bring it up when it's me and just
the other dude who did the dirty [ __ ]
I'll [ __ ] bury it in a second I know
exactly how to do it when I meet your
[ __ ] wife or your girlfriend I'll
[ __ ] yeah [ __ ] look you right in the
eye a sweetie how are you you look great
you've been going to the gym nah that's
fantastic I'll tell you your guy is such
a sweetheart goddamn it the other day
there was a cat stuck in the trees the
first guy yep
he did even wait for a ladder he just
started climbing up there what a swell
guy even if it's a dick even if it's a
[ __ ] dick what I'll then do is I'll
just avoid his girlfriend but I'm not
[ __ ] bringing it up dude that guy
really needs to go get his [ __ ] tubes
tied
what a [ __ ] all right YouTube YouTube
videos of the week YouTube all right
this one is [ __ ] absolutely insane
and if this was made by white people
this would actually be considered racist
on some level but it was actually made I
don't know if it's Japanese Chinese
people whatever the name of the video is
how to poop
and it is an animated cartoon teaching
children how to go poopie in the toilet
and it is [ __ ] insane it's [ __ ]
insane
it's great if you really have a problem
in your life that is just weighing on
you and it's sucking the energy out of
you and you just need to clear every
thought from your brain
please watch how to poop just go to the
mmm podcast com we got all these videos
that's the official fansite of the
Monday morning podcast just please go
and watch this thing it's [ __ ]
awesome we got really good I got three
really good YouTube videos this week the
next one is this guy made a Federal
Reserve music video that you have to see
it's uh he's doing basically a song
parody of the police's song every breath
you take it's [ __ ] great the guy
actually has a really good voice this is
[ __ ] funny as hell another great one
and then the last one is it's just a
highlight video of Jim Brown and there's
so many fans that say Jim Brown is
overrated and he couldn't play in
today's NFL did you just look at this
highlight reel the balance and the power
that this guy has is it's unfuckin
he's like running sideways half the time
or running backwards just plowing over
people the combination of balance of
power is like it's it's foreshadowing to
Earl Campbell or ol Campbell's the only
guy I've seen with like runs like this
and for everybody who thinks Jim Brown
couldn't play now yeah you're a hundred
percent wrong and I know what you're
gonna do you can look at how tall he was
and how much he weighed and say he would
get crushed in today's NFL that's the
wrong way to look at it if he took Jim
Brown and you put him in the modern era
what you have to do is also give him all
the modern tradition all the modern
sports science and all of that so he
would look like today's NFL football
with his with his skills his god-given
strength and balance and he would
[ __ ] tear up the goddamn League go
[ __ ] yourself I don't want to hear
another argument I'm sick of people
bringing up [ __ ] guys from nowadays
where they taking [ __ ] horse tranq
tranquilizers you can tell he would have
dominated in 1950 I would have dominated
in 1950 somebody fifty years from now
could dominate the NFL right [ __ ] now
begin it's called advancement jesus
[ __ ] christ
morons all right overrated underrated
for this week overrated every minority
and woman in commercials playing the
straight man to the dumb white guy I'm
not racist or misogynistic in the least
bit but enough is enough dude that's
[ __ ] hilarious and that's another
thing that that's not minorities or
women's fault that's because of all the
[ __ ] up [ __ ] white people have done
and we don't want to get sued that's why
they're doing it
not because they're trying to be
sensitive to other sexes or other races
they just make the white guy be the
stooge and all these [ __ ] commercials
because they don't want to get sued but
yeah it's starting to get annoying
there's always like the black guy
shaking his head is the [ __ ] white
guys slamming himself in the face with
like a [ __ ] rake that's not the way
you do it
that was actually a man/woman one
remember that one with a woman sit there
at the computer and that their husband
is outside [ __ ] he's got a guy
there's a beehive and he steak taking
like a broom handle and he's shoving it
up the [ __ ] beehive and then he gets
stung and she's sitting there rolling
her eyes like my husband he's a [ __ ]
[ __ ]
and they do that between men and women
and race and the [ __ ] the white dude
always has to be the [ __ ] but I mean
you know it is what it is but you know
you should be happy white person who
wrote that that they had that that's the
way they balance it out you know you're
still winning so quit your [ __ ]
crying alright also overrated in real
life and not what I see on TV is the
female carpenter or construction worker
I get I get that you've got a makeup
and try harder for all the [ __ ] you
deal with for [ __ ] sake crack a smile
for once in your life I really don't
know what he's bitching about their
female construction workers don't smile
enough all right underrated the PJs
Eddie Murphy was brilliant and the
claymation was the [ __ ]
back in the day why the [ __ ] don't why
the [ __ ] that show isn't on DVD is a
crime to all comedy one of the few shows
that is actually better with closed
caption on number 2 real musicians
anybody remember these people that
naturally play actually play their
instruments and none of that [ __ ]
auto tuner sampling machine and
turntables all of those are not [ __ ]
instruments well I mean you know I've
actually come to a place where I can I
can understand the brilliance of being
able to take pieces of so I think the
way that the Beastie Boys did it on
Paul's boutique where you took like 10
or 12 different samples looped them
together and created a new song I mean
there is there that is a talent you know
turntables that's just I don't get that
[ __ ] that's just I don't understand that
I'm too [ __ ] old to get that and I
don't get it I don't get mashups i
bitched about that before mashups are
the emperor's new clothes of music okay
all you have to do is pick two songs
that are the same tempo okay same beats
per minute then the lyrics will fit on
that other one then all you have to do
is just one that where the lyrics fit
the mood of them the new music you're
putting it over that's not that [ __ ]
difficult if you got sad sort of music
pick another sad [ __ ] song and just
stick that music under those sad lyrics
as long as the tempo was the same yeah
that's gonna work out
dude he took jingle bells and blended it
with Santa Claus is coming to town what
else do we got road trip
road trips with you [ __ ] bug it
buddy's never gets old that's that's
absolutely true that's why the hangover
was such a great [ __ ] movie real
lemonade not that Coke and Pepsi
packaged garbage but real [ __ ] with
[ __ ] pulp and flavor I like this guy
this guy's into old [ __ ] you know a pen
and paper not this [ __ ] laptop
horseshit
I don't remember my laptop ever crashing
I've actually said that alright that's
it that's the podcast for this week
everybody I hope you had a great week
and once again I'm looking forward to
the the Steelers Green Bay championships
and do me a favor bring up all Green
Bay's NFL titles I would really like to
try to start an underground debate about
that because I want them to start
counting NFL titles and I want to see
NFL franchises fly those NFL
championship flags you want it you know
I don't think the AFL one should fly
those flags it's part of the history if
you're a [ __ ] nerd like me I like
that type of [ __ ] I'm actually reading a
book right now called the greatest game
by Richard Bayly somebody gave me this
book and it's actually about the Bucky
Dent Red Sox that one one-day playoff
game and you know that's the great thing
about the Red Sox finally winning a
World Series and then winning another
one I can actually sit back and read
this book and it is it's a [ __ ] great
read it's a great read I recommend it
alright that's it that's the podcast for
this week everybody have a great week
I'm at The Improv in Addison Addison
Texas this week and what else do I got
coming up let's go on my website come on
guys hang in there don't shut it off
just yet don't shut it off just yet all
right then I'm gonna be at The Count
Basie Theatre in Red Bank New Jersey on
February 18th and I'm gonna be at the
new of Jesus Christ I mean to Tarrytown
Music Hall on the 17th of February Miami
Beach we have a new theater they had me
booked in another one but they had
already booked another act there so they
had to switch it up I'm actually gonna
be at the New World Symphony
Theatre on 17th Street Miami Beach
Florida on the the 4th of March the
Tower Theatre and Philadelphia look I
got a bunch of new dates on the website
Tower Theatre in Philadelphia on April
9th and this is the last one here I'm
gonna be at the paps [ __ ] out Jesus
Christ the link didn't work I would be
at the you know I was having such a
great podcast - on April 22nd I'm gonna
be at the Pabst Theater in Milwaukee
Wisconsin and right off the bat I just
want to tell you I'm blown away about
how many tickets sold the first day
Milwaukee was one of those cities where
I was like you know I don't know I don't
know I don't know if I'm gonna sell
tickets there you know it's not like New
York it's not Chicago it's not LA you
know so it's not one of those kinds of
cities but I don't it doesn't strike me
as a gator dude kind of City either it's
one of those middle ground ones so I
don't know where the [ __ ] I'm gonna fit
in it so I want to thank everybody in
Wisconsin who went out and bought
tickets
especially oh you know what somebody
sent me a [ __ ] email if I can just
from Escanaba Michigan saying they were
coming all the way down because they
remembered back in the day I played a
college up there in the Upper Peninsula
of Michigan and they said I went up in
front of 17 people in a cafeteria and
evidently I killed so the fact that I
actually put on a show in front of 17
people see how it see how that new
comedians if you're listening to this
podcast those [ __ ] shows matter years
later they'll actually show up if you
give them hell in front of 11 people
doing a nooner in the Upper Peninsula in
Michigan I actually [ __ ] remember
that gig I did a couple of gigs up there
though that's an amazing group of people
who live up there
I like how they embrace winners they
really have no choice but they actually
get real [ __ ] snowstorms you know
will you come out you open your door you
know and you get buried by like 9 feet
of [ __ ] snow you're walking down the
street on your snowshoes and you're
stepping over like frozen elk
right you know and they just state just
they embrace it he's opposed to all the
[ __ ] down here every time there's
four inches of [ __ ] snow every
goddamn fatty is running down to the
[ __ ] supermarket like they're gonna
starve to death I just want one news guy
during all that insanity we're gonna get
six to eight inches it's like do you
realize six to eight inches of snow it
that would barely reach the average
person up to their calf and considering
you can last about 35 days without food
as long as long as you have water okay
and snow is water stick it in your mouth
see what happens all right you're gonna
be [ __ ] fine
all right so sit tight all right there
sport that's what I want them to say I
want I want them to just [ __ ] sit
there and watch the Weathermen losing
his [ __ ] mind all excited that he's
the focus this week on the goddamn
[ __ ] newscast right or that night on
the newscast and then when they go back
to the anchor who's [ __ ] the
co-anchor cuz he's the goddamn alpha
male I want him to dress down that
[ __ ] that goddamn weatherman four
inches of snow Jesus Christ I could
stick my dick in that you could still
see the shaft the [ __ ] are you talking
about go [ __ ] yourself alright that's it
that's the podcast for this week you
guys have a great weekend yeah but [ __ ]
yourselves
don't thinking he should go see
you